depuis deux ans comme un chant d'or et
dans d'autres lieux hors norme
la musique électro se trouvent de
nouveaux espaces cette fois ci c'est
toto d'amboise d'organiser un concert
exceptionnel
on va pas transformer le château
d'amboise en discothèque
mais ça peut être de temps en temps un
événement qui fasse que l'on est
vraiment une sorte de volonté d'afficher
une ouverture sur le monde contemporain
et sur toutes les générations
une musique qui a toujours aimé l'air
libre mais dans les différents courants
de l'électro celui ci se veut plus de
l'amour est plutôt éloigné les grands
espaces désertiques des sound systems
pour les équipes du temps machine qui
ont signé la programmation rien
d'étonnant dans cette tendance
une partie des gens alors déjà on veut
un peu vieillot si donc ça ce tissu
analyse un peu alors que d'autres
restent dans une volonté de rester à la
marge et deux pas du tout avoir à faire
de l'institution mais ça c'est comme
tous les courants musicaux en fait
depuis à chaque fois qu'il n'existe
à la fiche de château machine le
tourangeau robin steiner à
l'international arnaud robot tiny césar
de la meilleure musique de film pour 120
maintenant par minute
le dandy du son c'est que l'électro ne
se cache plus dans des volutes de fumée
c'est quelque chose de beaucoup plus
populaires de plus accepter de plus
facile à organiser donc du coup c'est
vrai qu'on peut faire des beaux
événements dans les endroits comme ça
ici comme très institutionnel et les
chargés d'histoire
[Musique]
alors l'électro c'est aussi l'électro
chic sensuelle et sophistiquée